[Music]
here in this video we will showcase
marvel's dark gods and deities of
darkness well ever wondered what makes a
good story a good villain and what's
better than evil itself or at least the
incarnation of it in the form of
powerful dark entities and gods of
darkness
well marvel has quite a lot of these
actually and here we will list down 10
of these powerful deities and rulers of
the dark we will describe a little bit
on where they come from their origins
their powers as well as their evil
forces so strap yourself in and watch
till the end for a surprise entry and
also do tell us your favorite
firstly from the dark dimension we have
the faltens which include dormammu and
his extra dimensional sister umar well
we will actually only talk about
dormammu version from the marvel
cinematic universe because in this
iteration of him he is the supreme ruler
of a realm called the dark dimension
wielding frightening tremendous
supernatural powers of apocalyptic
proportions drama seeks to conquer every
universe in the multiverse as well as
that of earth unlike the corporeal drama
of the comics his mcu body seems to be
composed of the unique cosmic energies
of his own home universe and he can do
absolutely everything in his realm he
can shoot energy beams also his size and
control the entire dimension and is
basically a god in it
now another entry from the marvel
cinematic universe we have the ones from
the dark realm of savatelheim which
includes malekith and the dark elves
although not a god he is the ruler of
his immortal species and desires a
return to darkness to destroy light and
turn the universe back into an abyssal
void that it was before the big bang the
dark elf rays originated in the vast
primordial darkness that existed prior
to the creation of the manifest universe
where they reigned absolute and
unchallenged being the oldest known race
even predating the universe itself dark
elf technology was very advanced
surpassing that of even the asgardians
malkit waged a war on the nine realms
but was defeated in the past by ball the
father of odin and again in the present
day by thor
next coming from the dark abyss we have
null and his symbiotes null is the
originator of the symbiotes and an
eldritch god of darkness in venom vol 4
and the king of black he is the main
antagonist null is an entity who claims
to be the avatar of the primordial void
that existed between the sixth and
seventh universe he claims sovereignty
over the void and claims to be its
avatar but he is not the primordial
darkness itself now became a mythical
figure of heavenly dread as he waged a
war against the light he created what we
now know as the symbiotes the parasitic
amorphous aliens that born with hoes and
enhances their physical traits as well
as bring in new powers these symbiotes
under the influence of null form the
hive mind and their main goal is to
bring back the universe into darkness
and destroy all life
after that we come to the inhabitant of
an extra dimensional realm called
everyone and here we have the dweller in
darkness and his fear lords while not
exactly depicted with justice to his
character in the movie shangti the
dweller in darkness was so much more
than just a dragon kai to who is beaten
by 10 rings in the original take the
dwell in darkness was a fearlord and one
who feeds on fear to live and grow in
power he has actually destroyed the
multiverse in the past with the motive
of creating a never ending fear on all
creations so that he will quench his
hunger he also has other undefined
mystical powers like he can create
creases out of fear and he can turn
humans who die under his influence into
beings made of shadow he cannot be
killed but only be banished away to the
abyss only to eventually crawl back
slowly over time
from the dark pits of hell or otherwise
a realm called hades we get mephisto the
fallen angels and his various demons
what a dark gods list without a devil
himself or at least marvel's version of
one he is often considered as one of the
ultimate baddies an extra dimensional
demon who rules a fiery pocket dimension
that he calls hell or hades mephisto
calls this as hell in order to exploit
human beings belief in a single being of
absolute evil often referred to as satan
and he also has the appearance of one as
well mephisto's true origin has been
lost to time with many stars claiming to
tell the true origin but you can make up
your own mind over the years he has
built quite a repertoire he is the most
influential entity in earth's history
ranging from manipulating adam in the
beginning of time to creating the ghost
rider and many evil deeds in between and
all he wants is just the souls of humans
next we dive into the deep into the
version of lovecraft's earlier which is
really just the same but called kile in
the marvel universe so here we have the
marvel's version of cthulhu who is also
called kathan and along with his demons
called the nigeri they slumber awaiting
the right time to return to earth and
plunge the world into darkness again
k'thon was an elder god and became
corrupted by darkness and after a war
with the other elder gods he retreated
into his own dimension of galay he is
treated as one of the most dangerous
eldritch entities known in marvel able
to overpower and possess even the mighty
scarlet witch with ease kazan was also
the creator of many dark creatures
including the demonic nagarai man bats
werewolves and many more his most recent
entry back into the world was due to
garnish summoning him using the dark
hole only to be banished back with great
effort and a fusion of three symbiotes
now we come to the ruler of the fiery
world of masspelheim one of the nine
realms we have certa and his fire demons
sutter is portrayed as a massive
terrible monster with the strength of a
thousand scorching suns serta is a
massive fire giant that is over one
thousand feet tall he is more of a
natural force than a physical adversary
he has superhuman strength stamina and
durability that far outseats that of
thor's he may be a living flaming
creature capable of influencing the
earth's temperature from asgard itself
and manipulating cosmic energy for
diverse causes although not really from
the darkness his desire to see
everything burn and ruled by his fire
demons does sway him in the direction of
the dark gods and yes he is the one that
destroys asgard bringing about the
apocalyptic ragnarok
next we have a ruler of hundreds of
dimensions a creature that even domamu
and mephisto claims to be far superior
to them who is this yet another
lovecraftian-inspired eldritch entity
well let me just say what he said before
all was i was before time was i waited i
fed on screaming souls of the universe i
drank the spoiled milk of dead stars i
am the emptiness outside all
understanding i am shumar gorad
his words and it explains it all often
seen as a one-eyed cosmic octopus
monster shimmer garath was sometimes
stated to be omnipotent and is stated to
be the archetypal class 3 demon the
greatest of them all he is considered to
be one of the primal powers of chaos and
the greatest of the old ones in his
native dimension he is virtually
unstoppable and is unknown if he can
ever truly be killed his main objective
is to bring every universe into his dark
rule
so after that we have the entry from the
current seventh cosmos who are infected
with the horde a swarm of planet killing
insect creatures here we have the dark
celestials what is the list of marvel
gods without the celestial in it right
the dark celestials are a breed of
celestials infected and mutated by the
horde into rabid creatures before
arriving on earth the dark celestials
are also called the final host infected
and killed every other celestial in
existence and their bodies were held
down to earth to herald their arrival
these dark godly entities were the
opposite of what they were before and
only thirsted for destruction and
annihilation of earth and probably all
planets that are ripe for the taking
these dark celestials would have ended
it all if they weren't defeated by the
revived celestials
and lastly from deep space we have a
very new possession of marvel which was
originally from dark horse but now a
part of the marvel universe and these
are the aliens yes the surprise the
xenomorphs but we know not their exact
origin in this universe these xenomorphs
possess the same powers and features as
in the earlier movies their
biomechanical bodies stealth durability
and acidic blood they follow one
enigmatic figure also known as the
goddess the one in the dark which was a
biomechanical creature with vaguely
feminine traits she possessed a slender
frame with elongated xeno-like fingers
she also possessed curved goat-like
horns that curled around something that
appeared to be a biomechanical crown
their motive was as stated that once a
species grew arrogant with technology
they'll discover prometheus's fire to
wipe them out and start a fresh slate in
the galaxy and she was the end result of
humanity or other species venturing out
into space discovering them and back
into the darkness they will go
so there you have it guys marvel's 10
dark gods and rulers of darkness hope
you have enjoyed this video anyway with
that we come to the end of it so do hit
that like button for support and
subscribe as well to be a part of the
mind cue family but most of all smash
that bell icon for regular updates on
new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam